we have a big announcement to make on
the show the david pakman show as you
know it is going to be ending in a few
weeks in the sense that producer louis
is going to be departing from the
program uh now Louis this may come as a
shock to many in the audience we didn't
have an interview today specifically
because partially we want to uh discuss
this with you because I think it will be
both shocking uh debilitating and
exciting two different people in the
audience of course many people don't
want you to be part of the show many
people don't want me to even be part of
the show it's crazy people want the
david pakman show most people just don't
want the show to exist at all right yet
no devil that that's fair uh so let's
explore this louis up give us the
backstory and i will allow you to
present why you will be leaving the
great city of Boston uh and maybe that
classification is great is something
that is related to this story yes I
might not classify it that way but uh
city life is just is just not for me I
have determined and uh while I I enjoy
doing the show it's uh it is not for
show related reasons that I'm leaving
the show I just really don't want to be
anywhere near the city it's it's it
sounds like people aren't gonna believe
me when I say that but it's really that
simple talk a little bit about because
you are fair we've talked about sort of
the two big things that you're looking
for in your next place and the city part
is one of them and there's another and
this might be interesting insight into
Louis's psyche yeah okay well I mean I
it I I don't want to live in uh in
complete isolation and be a hermit and
be three hours from the nearest
restaurant okay so i would like to be
close to a a a population center but not
one the size of boston and that you
compared to so many of the population
centers as the call in this country
Boston's pretty small sure but still too
big for me and and so I would like to be
somewhere
a bit more rural but still close to uh
at least a medium-sized city and what do
you consider medium cuz it's so it's all
perspective coming from New York City
for me Boston is small it feels very
small it's four miles across or whatever
at you know very very small so for your
perspective what would be like a
suitable size metro area to be near but
not in yeah i would say between a
hundred and fifty thousand and three
hundred fifty thousand people would be
suitable okay uh but not to live in to
live near to live near right right and
so I I don't want to deal with the the
noise the smells the traffic the uh uh
the the cement and concrete everywhere
and all of that stuff and I also really
don't want to deal with winter uh I now
we're getting into part two yes part two
is I i really i really do not like
winter i am not designed to tolerate
winter well and is because of your
persian and jewish uh ethnicity no
probably mostly because I'm I'm uh
really fan okay and uh whatever that
means I mean it as it relates the winter
and and dealing with it uh so there's
all of that and uh just the the the the
city life just not feeling it need a
little bit more room a little more green
a little more space and a little more
peace and quiet so big picture you would
be looking to be outside of an area
outside of a city that's no more than
300,000 people in a part of the country
where and are you saying where there is
no winter or what would be like the low
winter temperature that you would
tolerate I mean mild very mild winters
would be fine right as so I'm thinking
uh that I wouldn't be dealing with
snowfall and that uh temperatures
wouldn't really be dropping below
freezing so 32 at the coldest day is
sort of your baseline and even that I
don't really like but yeah that would be
I I suppose that would be acceptable
from not dealing with the precipitation
and all that right for many people and I
think this will be sort of an eye opener
when we
you've explained to a few people off air
what's going on they say I'm genuinely
interested in this Louis because a lot
of people would decide where to live
based on things like proximity to family
how many people you know there and sort
of whether there's a specific job or
occupation that you would be
participating in but you've sort of
decided that the really important things
are uh climate and sort of our level of
urbanity for lack of a better term uh
well uh it's I know why people choose to
live why those decisions are important
to people why they decide to live in a
certain place like you mentioned close
to family uh employment opportunities so
on and so forth yeah but that is not
really like when I moved to Boston I
kinda convinced myself that I'd like it
and I thought to myself yes well my
family's here and while my friends are
here and uh and yet this job it's great
i love it but none of that ended up
battery knitting and so uh and maybe not
everyone is the same as me but first i
would like to find a place where i know
i can enjoy living right and then the
friends the the work all of that stuff
that will happen do you at have any
concern and I ask this not rhetorically
and not implying anything I say it with
peace and love do you have any concern
that sometimes the grass can seem
greener on the other side uh the grass
is uh it the grass is greener in other
places yes uh I I lived in austin for
two years and as many people know and
and this the the city stuff was really
getting to me there but despite that i
left about ten miles north of downtown
it was uh i mean i would take that over
boston at any day and did to be
perfectly honest i would take that over
western mass uh where i'm from any day
despite the city stuff that i'd have to
deal with in a place like austin so we
have a number of different special uh
Lois tributes planned we have something
that our segment producer and interred
in turn John uh astutely called Bistro
linguistics which is going to be airing
in over the next few weeks as Louis
transitions out and it is basically a
compilation of Louis's greatest
food-related moments and you know he's
had many of them on the show and we also
have John working on a really great
Louis highlight video he's literally
working on it as we speak uh I think I
can't see his screen but I'm sort of
counting on the fact that he is working
on that if you have any favorite louis
moments that you would like included in
this video by all means let me know and
then i will make sure that that gets to
John and uh uh we will continue to
celebrate Louis's uh involvement in and
contributions to the David Pakman show
over time and that there will be a lot
of uh compelling and and funny and
interesting moments for people and of
course the if I accidentally had a kid
I'd probably love the kid moment that is
a must on any compilation video uh yes
we were considering putting that in the
bistro linguistics video even though I
had nothing to do with it just because
of how how fond David is at it yeah uh
so we have as you know we have Rachel
who's been participating on the show one
day a week she's going to be adding a
second day starting very very soon we
also have producer Jason Shepherd who
has been under the tutelage of lewis as
i like to say uh are you taking it all
in Jason I mean this is you've been
thrown into essentially a uh well I
don't know I don't know what you've been
thrown into possum into a into a chasm
yet but uh how do you feel about Louis's
uh prioritization zand decision and and
how does it all feel because you
recently moved back to the Boston area
yeah so I feel like we're we're almost
just like switching roles lives here
where I was on the west coast for the
last kind of eight years and I'd almost
recommend where I was this place called
Santa Barbara California seems like it
was almost made for you never never
warmer than 70 never colder than you
know 65 yeah maybe snow one day every
other year on the mountains there so
i'll throw those that there but i feel i
have some big shoes to fill trying to
pick up everything that he is putting
down if you will and I feel like I'm you
know slowly getting it all but yeah
Louis I think if I can
speak for you and I don't mean to Santa
Barbara would be great except I think it
would be even to urban and you hate
California don't you oh I don't I don't
hate California I I don't like LA uh-uh
that's but California is also very
expensive and uh oh so that's kind of a
third thing right you're looking for a
place maybe where cost of living is
lower than on the coast so to speak on
the on the North East Coast and the west
coast that would be nice yes because um
well yeah right now it's just ridiculous
here in Boston and it's uh it's getting
a lot worse and I would like to avoid
that I'm sure boston of course probably
more expensive in santa barbara but uh
but California overall is very expensive
all right so that is the big
announcement we will be taking
everybody's feedback over the next
several weeks Louis will continue to be
here with us and we will uh continue
talking about it and I I'd know Louis
that there will be some people who will
email and will be absolutely devastated
by this decision of course we can
understand that there will be people who
will be absolutely thrilled by this
decision and of course we can expect
that and many people don't like you many
people don't like me yet they do watch
the show with regularity uh and there
will be many people who will assume that
this means i am the next person to
transition out of the david pakman show
which of course doesn't really make
sense but i know that now that the
window has been open some people will
hope that i will soon be gone from my
own show and that's to be expected right
it is yes i'm very curious to see what
the responses will be and uh yeah well
just uh yeah have at it yeah hit me like
I am and with peace and love we bring
you this announcement we will take a
break and a lot more to talk about next
hey this is sort of strange uh Donald
Trump spoke at sacred heart university
in Connecticut over the weekend and he
said to the audience hey I might
actually lie to you he turned to the
audience and pointed to a high school
kid that he introduced who's fighting
cancer and said that he wouldn't lie to
the kid whose name is Giacomo brancato
he said I wouldn't lie to the kid who's
fighting cancer but to all you people
I'm I
actually lie this was a very strange
speech that went on for about an hour it
was long it was rambling it had no
direction no common sense just a very
very strings strange speech and Trump
sort of capping it the cherry on top of
the speech is telling the crowd I might
just lie to all you people everybody but
this one kid next to me I might be lying
to it was very weird and I'll play it
for you this is one hundred percent
certain okay I'm telling mr. jacamo
right I might lie to you like Hillary
does all the time but I'll never lie to
Giacomo okay yeah alright Giacomo you
hold me to it we're gonna build the wall
but who who who is gonna pay for the
wall now funniest thing is that
immediately after saying he wouldn't lie
to Giacomo but he would lie to the
audience maybe he told a lie which is
that Mexico is gonna pay for that wall
there's no chance in hell Louis that
Mexico is paying for that wall which
will likely not even be built but there
he immediately lied to the audience I
guess it's good that he's finally being
honest and saying I might lie to you
here's line number one immediately after
it's it's good yes he's admitting that
he's a liar but in Donald Trump's
defense Dave yeah we're gave it the
devil's in the details here he never
said Mexico is gonna pay for a wall all
he said was who is going to pay for the
wall and the audience said it was Mexico
right I already told the lie but he said
100 live jacamo when he said we're gonna
build the wall cuz he knows it's not
gonna happen everything about this
campaign is nuts this particular rally
Trump showed up a half hour late no air
conditioning in the building remember
how hot it was this weekend in the
Northeast bunch of people had to be
treated for heat related symptoms Trump
rambles aimlessly for more than an hour
before telling the crowd that he might
lie to them if there were to be a
documentary made about the Trump
campaign I might be lying to you would
be a really good title I could see like
an independent Netflix tile documentary
called I might be lying to you and it's
all about the Trump campaign yeah I
might be lying to you or or this i will
tell you maybe just terrific remember
the good old days when mitt romney
seemed like so
of a run-of-the-mill out of step social
conservative I would love to go back to
those days before before the Republican
nominee was truly evidence that a
significant portion of this country has
has descended into total insanity Mitt
Romney was just a normal guy and he
looks great right now yeah he's just you
you like you said run-of-the-mill
republican uh nothing uh the major
donors big corporations or uh Joe the
Plumber type guys had to worry about you
know what is actually great about Trump
going up on stage and saying I might lie
to you PolitiFact a value evaluated that
statement and they've determined its one
hundred percent true this is the first
time PolitiFact has ever said something
Trump said is actually true usually it's
like a partially untrue pants on fire
total I Trump saying to the audience he
might lie to them finally is actually a
true statement according to PolitiFact
I've it great work done by PolitiFact I
don't think I needed them to know that
that was accurate but thank you what's
Trump even doing in Connecticut anyway I
mean there there's a poll where Trump is
only like five or six points behind
Hillary in Connecticut say that i was in
connecticut out that that's with
seventeen percent of respondents saying
they don't yet know who they're going to
vote for it it seems like a total waste
of time for Trump or you can't
completely forsake any state uh
regardless of what the numbers look like
they're if uh that's that's good
campaigning really i'd love to see Trump
here in massachusetts great use of time
that would be that that would be an
interesting when it actually would be
great as we could show up an interview
Trump supporters send me your thoughts
on this i'm on twitter at d pakman and
we have such a great show for you today
warby parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear warby parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses at some
point I know the audience will just stop
believing me because our reports about
Trump spokeswoman Katrina Pearson are
getting more and more and more
ridiculous over time but the reports
have all been true and i have yet
another report for you today that may be
hard to believe but it is all too real
after last week President uh
presidential candidate
Donald Trump said that President Obama
founded Isis now Katrina Pearson went
back on CNN and said it's actually
President Obama who invaded Afghanistan
now of course that's not true uh it
makes absolutely no sense to justice
just suggest that it was in 2001 under
george w bush that the united states
entered afghanistan but doesn't matter
of course this is the same katrina
Pearson who defended a call for a pure
breed president the same Katrina Pearson
who blamed a soldier's death in 2004 on
President Obama who didn't become
president until January of 2009 here she
is on CNN saying hey you know what
President Obama is responsible for the
u.s. invading Afghanistan take a look
pump campaign is back with us now in
Katrina I just want a factual seiko sake
of just correct information when you
said that Barack Obama took the country
into Afghanistan it was not during the
of course as you know during the Obama
administration when we first went into
Afghanistan shortly after we're talking
about Isis specifically okay but what
your statement was that the Barack Obama
took us into Afghanistan it was his war
it was President Bush who took the
country into Afghanistan shortly after
nine eleven but I want to get me we're
talking about founding of Isis Isis was
Isis came out of the Obama side of the
war oh is that not a fact no it is not
effect because in 2004 as I stated in
the last segment that aqi al Qaeda in
Iraq was started by Abu Musab al-zarqawi
and then in 2006 it morphed into Iraq
the Islamic state in Iraq and then later
became the Islamic state in Iraq and
Syria but really maggots yes and after
the search as but also Victor but
offered in 2004 Obama demonstration I
think the back of course this was also
Obama saying that they were the JV team
again the in competence of even
recognizing the threat while he was in
office and then to make it worse going
into Libya and creating a vacuum leaving
all of those weapons behind essentially
arming the enemy I hear that argument
that's not the argument that Donald
Trump has been making he is made over
the last several days that Barack Obama
was the founder of Isis and then said it
was sarcastic he's put his supporters
and his surrogates as we saw this
morning in a really difficult place not
knowing when he's being sincere when
he's being so Katrina nothing you're
saying is true i love how whenever she's
called out on her lies she tries to find
some middle ground like oh hey Katrina
when you said Obama took us to war in
Afghanistan you were completely
factually wrong okay but Victor can't we
agree that at least Obama is the
Antichrist and responsible for the death
of John F Kennedy no Katrina we also
can't say that and this is a known
technique Louis to try to find the
middle ground to sort of try to
establish some agreement from which then
you can have smaller differences but she
just fails miserably every single time
she really I i we we think she should be
fired because she seems to be completely
incompetent but yet who would take her
place is a real question uh Healy
Baumgardner he leave our daughter I know
it's scary and and uh yeah it's it's
just non-stop obama bashing i'm not sure
with that achieves she just spews
nonsense like trump all the time and I
although I will say this uh at least she
admits even if it's just a one word
admission she will admit when she said
something completely false she said no
in other words agreeing that no it was
not true what she said but a whole bunch
of other reasons why you should still
accept basically everything she says
without any kind of scrutiny whatsoever
anything else would be liberal media
bias I've actually been hearing from
people as Trump likes to say people are
telling me that President Obama actually
assassinated Franz Ferdinand and set in
motion the events that led to World War
one now I'm not saying that but people
have been telling me that Louis and
maybe we need to stop for a second and
figure out what the hell is going on and
there's only so far you can go in in
retro actively blaming Obama things that
happened when he wasn't even a senator
uh I feel like the late nineties of the
limit for what you can blame obama for
now of course he was basically a kid at
the time but but that that's about as
far back as you can go World War One
World War two that's a little too far it
is a little too far
uh but um miss Pearson and and Trump
might say you haven't taken it far
enough so that maybe even the Civil War
we can blame obama for dad is trying to
distance himself from an apparently cozy
in suspicious relationship with Russia
it's probably not a good idea to hang
out with someone who is rumored to be
Vladimir Putin's girlfriend when your
dad's campaign manager Paul mana forts
name appears on a handwritten ledger as
being entitled to somewhere between 12
and 13 million dollars in possibly
illegal payments from pro-russian groups
you may not want to be spotted arm in
arm with Vladimir Putin supposed
girlfriend but that's exactly what
donald trump's daughter Ivanka Trump
whose body Donald Trump is absolutely
stunned by as we've covered before just
as the best body and if it wasn't his
own daughter Trump with love to date her
uh Ivanka Trump was in a picture which I
will show you here with wendi deng
murdoch in croatia seemingly having a
grand old time and you'll notice that
last name Murdock Wendi Deng Murdoch
that is not a coincidence that is
because she is the ex-wife of Fox News
Overlord in chief Rupert Murdoch for
years rumors have swirled that Murdoch's
ex-wife and Trump's up buddy Vladimir
Putin maybe buddy is a bit much so
possible future buddy Vladimir Putin
were dating and the Kremlin has not
denied that relationship dang did flat
out deny the accusations at one point
but now anonymous sources within the
Kremlin are saying I oh no no this is a
serious relationship it seems to me it
would have been wise for Ivanka Trump to
avoid even the even the appearance of a
possible relationship here because she's
very involved in her dad's campaign
increasingly we see any number of
compelling connections between Donald
Trump's campaign and Paul Manafort and
Russia and Vladimir Putin and Viktor
Yanukovych etcetera etcetera and now it
turns out that they're vacationing
together it certainly doesn't look good
better yeah bad optics uh of all I'll
say this could just be the whole world
wide billionaires club
thing uh they're all friends they're all
buddies they all know each other but
certainly bad optics and this you should
know better if you're if you're the
daughter of the Republican nominee yeah
should know better and Jason you've
worked on movies that have scripts if
the 2016 narrative was written into a
Hollywood script I can only assume
producers would say this is so
far-fetched an unbelievable that it's
not worth producing this film because
it's just so clearly over the top and
it's actually what could end up in
history books I mean nope no Hollywood
producer would would believe this
because it's so insane I mean it could
be a really good sci-fi flick it could
be Trump gets elected and now it's the
you know United States of Russia and
America coming to you we need a
flowchart actually to show the
connections between Trump Rupert Murdoch
Paul Manafort Vladimir Putin Viktor
Yanukovych wendi deng murdoch Ivanka
Trump and probably Roger Ailes it is
somewhere in this flow chart don't you
think and we might as well include
gretchen carlson megan kelly while we're
at it oh megan kelly absolutely i mean
she her and drop uh and by the way
hillary clinton boot could probably be
on there she was at Donald Trump's
wedding Trump has donated to Hillary
Clinton this this election would
probably require the most convoluted and
extensive flow chart to figure out as
Trump likes to say what the hell is
going on yeah it's and we could call it
an incestuous election uh couldn't we
well do it that would be a huge
understatement yeah that's what it is so
there it is Ivanka clearly having a
grand old time with Vladimir Putin's
reportedly serious girlfriend and Paul
mana for 12-13 million bucks from
pro-russian groups no connection
whatsoever of course between the Trump
campaign and Vladimir Putin am I missing
some element of this is my flowchart
missing a few names let me know on
Twitter i'm on twitter at dpac man and
of course our reddit discussion forum at
david pakman.com slash read it the Trump
campaign is in total and utter chaos
remember not long ago when Donald Trump
fired that outrageous campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski and replaced him with
Paul Manafort
remember when all sorts of connections
between Paul Manafort and pro-russian
group surfaced including the New York
Times allegation that 12.7 million
dollars in payments potentially illegal
payments were in a handwritten ledger
for mana Ford and his organization all
of that was of course denied by the
Trump campaign and yet Paul Mann afford
has now been effectively fired as
Trump's campaign manager although in
name he will remain the campaign
chairperson to I guess make it seem like
they're not in total and utter chaos
Paul Manafort is basically out as the
effective manager of the campaign almost
as quickly as he was in he has been
replaced sit down for this he has been
replaced by two people number one this
Republican strategist and pollster
Kellyanne Conway okay I sort of
understand that she knows more about how
Republicans can appeal to women and she
has some expertise there make sense
although she's been a pretty aggressive
bomb thrower on CNN for the last six
months and Breitbart news CEO Steve
Bannon this is the same Breitbart news
that parrots all sort of conspiracy
theories including all of the recent
unfounded allegations about Hillary
Clinton being very very ill and on the
verge of death seemingly he now is going
to be the co campaign manager for Donald
Trump along with Kellyanne Conway uh
this comes the day after we learned
about numerous reports that serial
sexual assault accuse II actually no I'm
sorry I want to speak clearly this
evening serial sexual harassment accuse
e note the word that that the use of the
word accuse e and former fox news chief
roger ailes is also advising Donald
Trump and as I mentioned Paul Manafort
is going to stay on is the campaign
chairman clearly just for PR purposes to
make it seem like less of a shake-up
than it really is so think about it
Trump's campaign is now being advised
and managed by a combination of Roger
Ailes a right-wing bomb thrower who is
currently facing over 20 accusations of
sexual harassment
in his role at Fox News and the guy who
directs Breitbart news a total
right-wing bomb-throwing website that
also regularly publishes unfounded
conspiracies the real question Lois is
not to figure out exactly how nuts these
people are but to think about what they
can possibly do to the Trump campaign
well but one is put Trump on a
teleprompter right we stop all press
conferences and casual question answer
periods put Trump on a teleprompter
limit his interviews craft the message
very very specifically course we know
Trump seems crazy when he reads from a
teleprompter might not be the best idea
the other possibility and I mention this
because Breitbart has been a key player
in the Hillary is really sick conspiracy
theories like physically health-wise
sick maybe they can just frame the
entire Trump campaign no it's never been
about issues other than crazy stuff like
ban Muslims they could just make the
entire campaign about hey Trump is
healthy and Hilary isn't and try to
pivot to that I'm thinking out loud here
I don't know what they're going to do
yeah well well Trump's campaign is is
kind of a UH kind of a mess kind of a
disaster so do they say are there are
these people who are thinking we need to
clean this up a bit this needs to be
cleaner sleeker less insane Donald Trump
needs to shut up and stop putting his
foot in his mouth uh or are they going
to go down the Breitbart route yeah and
oh boy if you thought it was ugly before
a lot of people are saying now it's
actually going to get ugly really yet
what was it before I mean that's amazing
I can't wait for the finger-pointing
right i mean so many people have been in
and out it's been like a revolving door
in this abortive campaign that at this
point i would believe that divine you
know we always say it's so pompous to
think that God if he or she exists gets
involved in the politics in one election
cycle in one country on one continent in
one on one planet in one solar system in
one galaxy of this amazing universe that
he or she created I would actually
believe it if somehow Trump is able to
turn this around and put together what
seems like a normal campaign I would
only believe that it were possible
through divine intervention well I'd go
the opposite uh with
that I would say that if it's possible
for Donald Trump to become president uh
intelligent design is a farce and were
really just incredibly dumb creatures
that did come from uh fish in
single-cell organisms major major
conspiracy theories swirling around
Democratic presidential candidate
Hillary Clinton's health Alex Jones is
conspiracy site info wars Breitbart both
very involved in spreading those
conspiracies they put up a picture from
februari of an icy winter day when
Hillary Clinton had slipped on ice to
suggest that in the last few weeks she
was frail and unstable on her feet
they're slowing down video of her in a
few different moments to the campaign to
make it look like she has these extended
periods of instability and
disorientation etcetera etcetera
etcetera but the real story might be
elsewhere remember when late last year
Trump released a letter purportedly from
his doctor talking about how just how
awesome Trump's health is in every way
his tests are tremendous he tested so
well for everything blah blah blah blah
blah he did very very well he did very
very well on that doctor's letter he
finally won again with that doctor's
letter all of the attention on Hillary's
supposed medical records gave a doctor
named Jennifer Gunther the idea to look
more closely at that letter but that
Donald Trump supposedly received from
his doctor and she determined that the
Trump letter actually warrants quite a
bit of scrutiny let's start first with
just showing you if you're watching here
the letter big picture okay this is the
letter reportedly from the office of
Jacob bornstein and Harold bornstein
both doctors and okay it's a letter
first problem is as you see there the
first line is to whom my concern already
strange because typically these letters
are written up with some cut in English
incorrect grammar but maybe from a
template or it's a very short letter so
have you know very well fine is just a
typo maybe doesn't really mean too much
second problem with the letter is it
doesn't even have a working web address
if you go to Harold bornstein md.com
which is there you get a missing website
redirect the sort
placeholder page which I'll show you uh
in terms of what it looked like as of
this morning and it's one of these
websites that show up essentially when
there is no website there whatever
domain registrars being used put
something up there in addition to this
dr. gunther says it's very weird that a
doctor would even include their email
address in this kind of letter because
number one uh if you're making a media
release about someone so notables health
you don't want to get a flood of emails
and that relates to reason number two
why you wouldn't include an email
address which is you can't say anything
HIPAA laws would not allow you if people
start emailing you as a result of this
letter what were you gonna tell them you
can't tell them anything because HIPAA
laws preclude you from doing that uh now
let's move on to the bottom of the
letter to look at something else and if
you look at the bottom of the letter
you'll see that it refers to the
department of medicine section of
gastroenterology at Lenox Hill Hospital
in New York City Lenox Hill has a
division of gastroenterology not a
section and by the way dr. Borenstein
isn't even listed on the website as a
member of that uh division we will show
you a picture of who is listed there dr.
swaminathan dr coral it's and cut the
day in and David Herbert Robbins in
Anthony star pauley but number one no
section of gastroenterology even exists
at this hospital and the division uh
does not even list dr. bornstein dr.
Borenstein is affiliated with Lennox
Hill but he has nothing to do with
gastroenterology why would he sign the
letter that way why is it referred to by
a name that is not even the name of the
actual gastroenterology department it's
all very very strange and then lastly
according to dr. Gunther the language of
the letter is very very strange I think
we have a bit of this to show you as
well no doctor describes tests as quote
only positive results nor astonishingly
excellent it is also very weird that a
doctor would reserve refer
to results as positive because usually
in medical language when you've tested
positive for something when a test is
positive that means you have a condition
or disease you would not if you are
trying to talk about how great someone's
health is say oh all the tests were so
positive because in medical language a
positive test means yes you do have a
condition that we are testing for weird
isn't it very strange yeah my guess
would be that this was just some type of
favor right that this was just a favor
that the the Donald Trump asked for and
I well billionaires who knows if he's
relieving a billionaire tour I have a
way to get these favors and maybe that's
what this was also completely
unbelievable that the letter would say
this is the healthiest individual this
would be the healthiest individual ever
to be elected to the presidency doctors
usually exercise caution uh doctor dr.
Borenstein certainly did not examine the
health of every president of the United
States so how on earth could he make the
determination that Trump would be the
healthiest President of the United
States unless Jason this is a doctor who
in addition to having very very weird
formatted letters had a time machine or
something like that pressure is a time
machine he also wrote the other letter
about Hillary and maybe maybe some
letters to uh you know miss maintained
aliens or some other conspiracy theories
I can think of but yeah very very
strange and lastly the header can we put
that the full letter back up just for a
second Jason the the the first image
that we had for the segment you'll
notice that the letter in at the top
refers to Jacob bornstein and Harold
bornstein uh as far as we know not not
both of those doctors were still alive
as of 2015 uh so so that's yet another
wrinkle in the entire thing maybe this
was some old copied and pasted header I
don't know if we're going to start
scrutinizing medical letters this is
definitely at the top of my list I don't
know about you Oh bleep we're not ones
to buy into conspiracy theories this
thing is this something's up with this
there's something very very strange
about the send me your thoughts i'm on
twitter at d pakman quick story i want
to mention for you this is the height of
irony tony Perkins is press
into the Family Research Council this is
an organization considered an anti-lgbt
hate group by the Southern Poverty Law
Center tony Perkins one of the most
fervent anti-gay activists that this
country has seen was left homeless by
the destructive flooding that has
ravaged southern Louisiana killing more
than 10 people destroying tens of
thousands of homes Perkins of course has
previously claimed that God uses natural
disasters like hurricanes and flooding
to punish people for sinning including
gay people for being gay he now has had
his own home destroyed apparently by the
Lord Almighty uh what does this tell us
Louis it tells us that if he's right
then he is gay or gay sympathizer he's
been hiding it all along yeah or it
tells us uh absolutely nothing well he
was asked about this right and his
explanation was that uh this was not
this particular flood right so now that
it's applying to tony perkins who says
typically god sends floods to punish gay
people for him it wasn't at all about
any sin or homosexuality or anything
like that but it was quote an incredible
encouraging spiritual exercise to take
you to the next level in your walk with
an almighty and gracious God who does
all things well of course when other
people suffer misfortune at the hands of
natural disasters its punishment for
sinning when he suffers it it's a test
sent by God to make him even stronger
and rest assured the the gay people who
were affected by the same flight yeah
for them it was punished oh absolutely
yeah yeah yeahs can God's gaydar be
wrong if God is all-knowing and
all-powerful and you buy into this type
of nonsense Jason could God's gaydar be
miscalibrated so to speak certainly not
not only not not at does not fall within
the worldview of someone like tony
perkins that there would be any kind of
mistake made to be clear i don't wish
harm upon people i don't wish for
flooded floods to destroy people's homes
but i don't think i'm a bad person for
recognizing the irony mi know now this
is uh this is something that clearly he
needs to now explain to his
his sheep oh yeah and uh that they're
not even gonna think about it
unfortunately they're just gonna believe
everything he says and maybe they even
forgot about his punishment comments
before maybe they've been tested to
become stronger by God because uh they
oppose homosexuality so God is picked
them say you're so good for opposing
homosexuality I'm gonna send a flood to
your area in order to actually
strengthen you even more uh and of
course we know god works in mysterious
ways they're very mysterious ways but
the good news is the more money you give
to this guy yeah um the better more
gobble like you yeah